بايدن يدخل على خط الازمه المصرفيه في
الولايات المتحده اسرائيل تفرج عن شيخ
الاسرى الفلسطينيين عرس لبنان الكروي
يتحول الى ساحه حرب هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
وصفه حاله من الهلع من تكرار ازمه عام
2008 دخل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على خط
ازمه المصارف في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه متعهدا بمحاسبه الاشخاص
المسؤولين عن افلاس بنكي سيليكون فعلي
وسجن بانك
بيضا الامريكيين بان ودائعهم بامان اعلن
البيت الابيض ان الرئيس توصل الى حل لازمه
البنكين في اعقاب اجتماع وزيره الخزانه
ورئيسي الاحتياطيه الفيدرالي مع مجلسي
ادارتهما
بعد 17 عاما في الاسر افرجت السلطات
الاسرائيليه اليوم عن شيخ الاسرى
الفلسطينيين فؤاد الشوبك من مدينه غزه وهو
بعمر الثالث والثمانين الشوبكي كان يتبع
في سجن عسقلان وطوال سن اعتقاله اقترن
اسمه بالقاب متعدده ابرزها شيخ الاسرى حيث
كان المعتقل الاكبر سنا في السجون
الاسرائيليه وخلال 17 عاما في الاسر فقدت
شوبك زوجته عام 2011 كما تزوج اربعه من
ابنائه السته واليوم لديه تسعه احفاد لم
يرهم في حياته
في حدث كان يفترض ان يكون عرسا كرويا في
لبنان تحولت مباراه كره قدم مصريه بين
فريقي العهد والانصار الى معارك بين مشجعي
الفريقين من جهه وبين مشجعي الانصار وقوات
الامن من جهه اخرى
العرس تحول الى ساحه حرب بعد من انطلقت
هتافات طائفيه وسياسيه من مدرجات الفريقين
وقبل وقوع كارثه تحصد ارواح المشجعين تدخل
الجيش اللبناني للحيلوله دون تفاقم الوضع
الى السودان الان حيث تداول الناشطون على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو يظهر
رئيس السوداني السابق عمر البشير خارج
السجن في عزاء شقيقه وصفه طفاه تعالى بين
انصاره من الحضور البشير تلقى العزاء في
وفاه الشقيقه بمنزل الاسره الكائن بضاحيه
كافور شرق الخرطوم بحري بعد ان منحه قاضي
المحكمه المختصه اذنا بذلك لمده ساعتين
فقط مما اثار خروجه من السجن انتقاده من
بعض الناشطين
لقطات لافته وغريبه بالجمله شهدها حفل
توزيع جوائز الاوسكار هذا العام لكن
اطرافها كان ظهور حمار حقيقي على منصه
توزيع الجوائز التي يكرم عليها ابرز المع
نجوم السينما المذيع الساخر جيمي كيمو
فاجا الجميع باحضاره حمارا على خشبه
المسرح اثناء تقديم الحفل مشيرا الى ان
الحمار ويدعت جني بالمناسبه هو الذي شارك
في فيلم ادب عن شيشيز اوب اني